hi guys I'm Abby Shar welcome to Abby's
kitchen with the new year here there's
bound to be a whole slew of new fad
diets and while the hcg injections and
diet is actually an old diet it's
recently had a huge resurgence and
become popular again thanks in part to
social media here we go so as per usual
I'm putting on my research lab coat and
putting this diet to the test to chat
about whether or not the HCG diet is
safe legal and most importantly if it
even works so like I always say this
video is for educational use only and
should a no way replace medical advice
or recommendations from your own doctor
who's trained in providing you with care
tailored to your specific needs if you
plan on starting any diet of any kind
please speak to your own health care
provider okay let's get into it so first
of all what is the HCG diet so HCG
stands for human chorionic gonadotropin
and it's the main hormone produced
during pregnancy in the first few months
of pregnancy HCG levels rise doubling
approximately every 48 hours as it
allows for the production of important
hormones like estrogen and progesterone
infertility centers across the country
hcg injections are often used to help
with both male and female infertility
this is the only case where hcg
injections are legal for use in Canada
and the United States so then where does
this diet come from well back in the
1950s a doctor theorized that because
HCG levels can regulate caloric output
and actually burn more calories during
pregnancy
he believed that injecting HCG into non
pregnant people could actually burn more
calories on top of that wild theory he
also believed that hcg injections would
burn fat and undesirable areas like the
stomach waist and thighs as if you can
actually have power over where your fat
is stored in your body so from this
theory the HCG diet was born and it
looked kind of like this
number one take regular hcg injections
and number two go on an extremely low
calorie diet about 500 calories per day
that's not a lot of calories now since
the 1950s the HCG diet
looks a little bit different but you can
now get HCG in pills lozenges sprays and
homeopathic drops aka water however none
of these have been approved by the FDA
or are considered legal so what does the
diet look like well there's three phases
of an HCG diet number one the loading
phase so in this face you eat a high fat
high calorie diet for two days around
250 grams of fat per day and you begin
taking the hcg injections now 250 grams
of fat is a lot of fat in one day in
fact it would be equivalent to eating
about 8.5 avocados or one cup of olive
oil depending on what your diet looked
like previously you might not feel so
hot number two is the weight loss phase
so in this phase you limit calories to
five her calories per day while taking
HCG injections for up to 40 days that is
literally one store-bought muffin or
like a small burger and a side salad all
freaking day and then there's the
maintenance phase in this face you stop
taking the hcg injections and you start
to slowly increase calories so does the
HCG diet work short answer is No well
the diet was popular in the 1950s since
then there have been numerous studies
that have found that the diet is
ineffective in terms of long-term weight
loss we know from lots of research that
these types of diets that are starvation
based do not work reviews on this diet
have found that short-term weight loss
is possible but this is because of the
intense calorie restriction not the hcg
injections and when I hear the words
calorie restriction a few major concerns
come to mind first of all there's no way
a person following this diet is going to
get enough nutrients for their body to
function properly secondly if you're not
giving your body enough calories your
body's gonna start burning stored fat
and muscles to keep you alive and no
it's not going to exclusively burn fat
where you want it to third this diet
does not teach a person any lifelong
eating habits once they finished the
diet a person will likely go back to
eating their regular eating patterns and
the evidence has shown us time and
I'm again that they'll likely gain that
weight back and maybe even more this
evidence was best seen in the famous
Biggest Loser study where the
participants metabolic rate declined 500
calories lower than what would be
naturally expected for the reduced
weight the result of course is that
despite continuing to restrict calories
and exercise intensely it would be
virtually impossible to keep the weight
off that they lost now another big
question is this HCG diet even safe well
there are a lot of dangerous side
effects to hcg injections including
blood clots deep vein thrombosis leg
swelling over stimulation of the ovaries
false pregnancy tests fluid retention
shortness of breath difficulty breathing
and gall stones that's not even
considering the 5m calorie a day diet
which of course on top of all that would
put one at risk of things like vitamin
and mineral deficiencies like anemia
muscle loss reduced mint metabolism GI
issues infertility fatigue headache and
low blood sugar finally is it even legal
to take hcg injections and supplements
if you're not taking HCG injections
because of fertility issues under the
supervision of a doctor then no taking
HCG products for weight loss is
considered illegal and fraudulent
because they've not been approved or
shown to be safe for weight loss so
you're really dealing with shady people
if they're recommending that you take
them bottom line I am sorry to tell you
guys but there is no quick fix when it
comes to weight loss diets that promise
you a quick fix our super restrictive
diets in disguise and they often can do
way more harm than good and put your
ultimate health at risk if you choose to
pursue weight loss I definitely
encourage you to focus on slow gradual
behavior changes that last adopting
lifelong healthy habits even in the
absence of weight loss is much better
for your body then any illegal
restrictive diet can ever be well guys I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment if you have any fad diets
that you want me to review subscribe to
the channel and I'll see you next time
nice kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]